i write down one or two words
that will tell me
about a joke usually one or two words
can lead me down the right path this one
just says
eating ass and i have no idea
i don't know if it's a
reminder
oh i remember the joke oh my god okay i
know you're just here to have a good
time i know you're not trying to be an
[ __ ] so and i like your energy dude i
like your personality i just wish you'd
shut the [ __ ] up
you know what i mean look man we've all
been drunk before i totally get it i
mean i've never been drunk off a white
zin so i have no idea
i have no idea what kind of buzz that is
that seems
that white's in high oh it gets you
crazy
oh eating ass okay yeah yeah
by the way when you said it i was like i
thought i'm like i must have heard that
wrong
why would someone scream that at me what
i love about having older kids is that
they keep you in the loop of like what
is
current
right it keeps you kind of current so
like i know and i would ask them things
about
musicians or shows or and i asked him
about trends right and i think what's
going on in high school that i wouldn't
believe and he goes okay i'll go
something for you
and he goes but you're he goes you're
not i don't think you're ready for this
i'm like
i go i think i'm ready dude he goes okay
he goes but did you know that like uh
everybody's just eating ass now i go
what
and he goes yeah we love it everybody
loves it it's cool everybody loves it
everybody loves it
honey what do you mean he loves it he
goes yeah everybody loves it everybody
does it dad everybody eats ass
and he goes you wouldn't understand i'm
like first of all slow your roll man
it's not that us older people don't
understand eating ass
yo but
you had to earn it
yo yo you know it's not that we didn't
do it but it was like five years we've
done everything let's take a look at
your [ __ ] you know what i mean
it wasn't hey thanks for the ride home
you know
you had to earn it and i'm gonna tell
you something else you guys didn't seem
as shocked as i was that's shocking to
me
maybe
maybe i'm not as sexually advanced as
you were but in high school if someone
had tried to eat my ass i'd have called
the cops i'm telling you right now
i had a mirror out like i don't i don't
know you you don't have my last name
what are you doing back there
and then
i was so [ __ ] blown away he goes but
you know what you'll be happy to hear i
go what he will be you'll be happy to
hear that a lot of girls are leaving
high school virgins i'm like well i
don't know if i'm happy to hear that but
good for them he goes yeah he goes there
they're they want to save themselves for
marriage i'm like that's nice too and he
said yeah they do anal i'm like what
he goes but they're virgins i'm like are
they i mean
i know technically they are but that's
not really the spirit of it do you know
what i'm saying like
and i know that's definitely not her
nickname when she walks down the hallway
like
nobody's like hey there goes that virgin
you know
but here's what really blew me away is i
call i called a friend of mine who's my
age and he's dating so i asked him i go
hey man
i go you uh
you eating ass
and he goes
got to bro
and i go what he goes if you want to be
in the game and you're not eating ass
you're not in the game
and i go what he goes plus the butthole
is cleaner than the mouth i was like
nope
he goes no i read it in a book i'm like
well that's a book of lies is what that
is that sounds like a book written by a
dude trying to get a girl to eat his ass
that's what that sounds like
check out chapter two get back there
24 day i'm living liver just to make it
through another 24.
but you know how the story goes another
day another dollar howler 7 p.m once
again and breaking up the public